my move University YouTube videos are
offered on a pay what you like basis if
you'd like to pay for the use of the
videos visit my website at move
University comm click on the pay what
you like link at the top of the page and
follow the instructions on that page
thank you and enjoy so in this video I
want to talk a little bit about the
fatty acid synthase complex the actual
enzyme itself so we mentioned before
that fatty acid synthesis we have a
condensation reaction the first
reduction dehydration second reduction
process repeats every time that we add a
two carbon unit and then beta oxidation
of course is essentially the opposite we
mentioned that before now what is the
name of the enzyme that catalyzes fatty
acid synthesis well it's not just an
enzyme enzyme complex I want to stress
that and I'll get to what that means
just a moment and of course what is
called a fatty acid synthase that should
be pretty obvious at this point I want
to stress that so that's emphasized now
basically it's a large complex and it's
specifically a dimer and I'll kind of
show you that in just a moment or
towards the end of the video and it's
got a bunch of different catalytic sites
in the complex and this is kind of how I
imagined it here I've drawn this this is
kind of how I imagined it it's not
really how it looks and not how it's
depicted it's just like how my brain
understands it so hopefully you can
understand it the way I understand it
because I felt this was much easier to
understand then than other diagrams and
stuff so um what it's got here I kind of
drew like a pizza and I cut it up into
eight sections with a circle section in
the middle and what I've got here is
that this little site in the center is
the ACP or the acyl carrier protein and
that ACP has a really important feature
which is this phospho pentacene
prosthetic group now that's actually the
it's it's what it does is it forms a bio
ester thio ester bond in the same way
that acetyl co a does in fact that
phospho panteth in group is the same
business and as that of acetyl co a it's
the same thing so it can form bio ester
linkages like acetyl co a does and what
it does is
is it acts like what I put here acts
like a crane so if you imagine a crane
it kind of just it go shoot supp out
like this this is how I imagine it again
it's carrying the substrate and what it
can do is it can kind of swing around
from site to site taking the substrate
to each of these sites where a reaction
can occur a reaction can be catalyzed so
what it does is it carries the substrate
from one catalytic site to the next
according to the reaction that needs to
occur okay so now let's get to the
actual catalytic sites so there are
three domains cleverly named domain one
two and three so domain one I've got
here written or sort of depicted in
yellow so these first three sites here
this atm T and C e are stand for acetyl
transitways Millenial translates place
and condensing enzyme respectively and
those are our three catalytic sites in
domain one domain two is all that's in
orange and that's that's those there and
the domain three is just this T which is
the sty Oster ace now the details of
these reactions will be in another video
or I should show you the steps but
essentially what I want you to
understand is that the substrate will be
carried from site to site where each of
the reactions can be catalyzed so just
to give you a quick heads-up acetyl
translation malonyl translational is
what they do is they basically attach
the acetyl group and the Millenial group
to the ACPs prosthetic group and then
there instead of being called acetyl co
a and Mallon yoko a goal be called a
single acp and malonyl acp because
they'll be attached to the acp the
condensing enzyme is what actually links
the the acetyl group and the male anil
group it's actually called acyl malonyl
acp condensing enzyme and it's called
that because it connects the acyl group
to the Melanie over that's coming in to
make a keto acyl group Akito acyl
structure which is called keto acyl acp
so that's not the condensing enzyme is
also called keto acyl synthase for that
reason that keto acyl group moves to the
next site which is
the beta keto acyl acp reductase
depicted by kr here and then then we
have the da to the ER and the T so on
and so forth but essentially it kind of
goes like I said in this direction just
like this around the way until and we
keep adding two carbon units by
following this path right so the for
actual steps of fatty acid synthesis or
I call it beta reduction is the
condensation step which kirkland
condensing enzyme the first reduction
with this keto a so ACP reductase and
then the dehydratase right the
dehydration occurs there and then the
second reduction occurs at the ER where
i with the annual acp reductase site
so those four sites are going to be
continually active when we continue keep
adding those two carbon units at a
certain point will create palmitate
right after these these are rounds after
we've had enough of these rounds to
yield palmitate once palmitate is
attached to the acp what happens is
domain 3 with the the fiyo esterase what
it does is it Cleaves the thio ester
bond between palmitate and the acp and
what that does is that frees up that
frees up a palmitate from the fatty acid
synthase complex so then after that all
that has happened you release that fatty
acid into the cytosol okay so how many
catalytic I shouldn't have put this here
catalytic sites in total are there on
the fatty acid synthase
well everything with an ace right ace
ace condensing enzyme arson face ace ace
ace basically it's everything except the
ACE the acyl carrier part in the ACP so
that's one two three four five six seven
so seven it's all except the ACP because
the ACP is not actually a catalytic site
right it's just carrying the substrates
from one
site to the next okay so that's pretty
much it now I mentioned the dimer before
so this is like I said this is my
imagination how I kind of see it but
scientists kind of depicted it affected
by this dimer so you have this unit over
here and this unit over here so of
course everything in yellow is still
domain one I think an orange domain two
then the fiyo s3 is domain three so we
kind of have this one kind of in you
know going this direction this one going
the opposite direction and they're
connected they can be connected here at
there with disulfide bonds okay to be
honest I don't really know too much
about this and what's going on with it I
just kind of use my imagination to
understand the the complex itself which
is a little bit easier for me and I hope
it's easier for you too anyway I hope
that video is helpful thank you for
watching